published yesterday so we have the press
release on the D bps the DEF budgetary
plans published the Greek statements the
reappointment of the euro working group
chair and there are a number of
documents that were going to publish
soon then the letter of the president
sent a note to president Michel which is
the outcome of this meeting the ESM
related documents and the reports of the
high level working group chair on the
banking Union Commissioner thank you
first of all thank you very much Mario
for your kind words
it was in fact my first Eurogroup and
I'm grateful to Mario that you were
capable to end it before midnight it was
three minutes before midnight eight
minutes before midnight
yes we presented our reports on Greece
on Cyprus and on Spain about Greece I
have to say that I had on Tuesday a very
positive meeting with the finance
minister Christos stai chorus and that
the country according to our report is
well on the road to recovery
obviously as Mario said challenges
remain but government is strongly
committed to face these challenges and
also yesterday during the discussion
that we had in the Euro group the
minister was very clear about these
commitments and so the council moved
forward for this decision of the
disbursements of 767 millions following
the agreement that we had last year so
good news for Greece from this point of
view and
the Commission and ESM will continue in
their cooperation with the Greek
authorities I have to say that we had an
interesting and good discussion on the
draft budgetary plans not so much on the
single draft budgetary plan of the 19
countries in this case I present the
opinions adopted by the Commission but
on the general fiscal policies and I am
convinced that we need more than ever to
have coordinated and differentiated
fiscal policies we are not 19 separate
economies we are a monetary and economic
Union and I think we should work in the
next year's to build on this concept
this means first of all compliance with
the existing rules maybe we will discuss
the rules but now we have to comply with
them
second readiness to be more active in
the fiscal policy should the downsize
risk that we are seeing somewhere
materialized and the Eurogroup statement
the Eurogroup communique is openly
mentioning this readiness and third I
think we should be ready to increase in
the medium-term our public investment
especially those commits connected to
climate change and the environmental
transition we made as Mario said
progress on ESM I think
we are reaching a positive agreement and
this positive agreement is inside a
package we didn't discuss this time of
the B ICC but it is part of the package
on the sm you know that the Commission
is not a signatory of the treaty but we
were active in facilitating the process
and we are having a memorandum of
cooperation with the SM establishing the
forms of our cooperation I have to to
say that I repeated yesterday what is
our thinking as a commission that the
perspective should be in the future to
have the integration of the SEM in the
EU legal framework this remains from the
Commission point of view a goal finally
concerning it is I would say cynic and
abhi it's it's something it is very
relevant the fact that this door
appeared to be closed until a couple of
years ago a couple of years ago it
appeared to be closed and now it has
been reopened well the process will not
be easy and the discussion yesterday was
very clearly showing the differences and
Mario was very precise in referring what
he will report to the European Council
on this beginning of discussion but the
beginning of the discussion was there
so we have I think the possibility to in
the next period we take the commitment
to have it in the next five years which
appears very long but would be very
challenging and very relevant to have
this third leg of our package complete
so small steps but I think relevant
steps in the right direction Thank You
Klaus raylene from the USM yes good
morning everybody